we've got John McClane back here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you John I'm
great reg how are you welcome to Texas
well well I appreciate that as always
and about how are you question is you
know obviously a pleasantry to begin but
I'm genuinely concerned about your
mental state John because I'm seeing
your mock draft right here and I see
it's a mock draft 9.0 and I'm wondering
how that does not turn your brain to
some form of mush with a nine different
mock drafts John what about reg my brain
was much to begin with and so I just
turned in my tenth and final mock draft
that is my official mock draft it'll be
on the website later today and in The
Chronicle tomorrow and I am amazed by
was the to beat people I respect the
most in Cleveland Toni gross he says Sam
Darnell Mary Kate cabbage she's saying
it could be Josh a Lenore Baker may feel
so that means it must be Josh Rosen Wow
now that would tear the roof off this
sucker for sure if that happens but what
are you hearing what are you hearing
outside of obviously the beep reporters
were on I just turned in damned Arnold
and my second sake when Barclays
although rich I got to say if you're if
you're Dave gentlemen and your pad
Shermer and Pat's a quarterback coach
with an offensive quarterback background
how can you pass up a chance to take a
quarterback second overall when you
think you'll never be drafting that high
again and if you were bad and you had to
play them then you could always try you
like to a contender before the trade
deadline the first week of November and
you might be doing them a favor that
being said I'm going with Berkeley well
here's here's how I'll answer that
question how do you not choose one
second overall when you're not going to
choose that high is that you might be of
the mindset of my first our guest Troy
Aikman where the mindset of Sean Payton
who told Peter King and the mmq be a
couple Monday's ago that he doesn't
think that there's a franchise
quarterback in this draft and Arnold
might be the only one who is and if
Donald goes first overall and the Giants
are the only team really in the top five
who really are they technically they're
not quarterback needy right now
and they're not quarterback needy
because they haven't gotten it right for
so long like the like the Browns and the
Jets you don't have to do it really when
you think about it so you don't and they
are running back needy has been forever
since they've had a thousand yard rusher
and we all know Barclays the best
prospect in the draft and nobody can
help a quarterback more than a running
back so I think that the Giants should
take him and don't know if they will but
that's his going in my mock draft and
mike Mayock said last week and I know
you'll talk to Mike about this for 24/7
for the next four days but Mike pointed
out you know he crossed all the boxes
and luck and went and none of these
prospects crosses all his boxes
therefore none of them are guaranteed
john mcclane here on the Rich Eisen show
from the Houston Chronicle
and John I've been using for the for the
conversation as to say the Jets might
have overspent from going to six to
three and even if the Browns do choose
Baker Mayfield first overall that none
of it matters about how much draft
Capital you've used or whether you might
have over drafted or or you know gone
over your skis based on where somebody's
draft position should be if the
quarterback hits and the example I've
been using is the Houston Texans that
there's I imagine not a single member of
the Texans organization lamenting that
they're not choosing fourth overall
despite having earned that spot with
last year's disaster after - Shaun
Watson got hurt because DeSean is
clearly the man corrects here's the way
everybody looks at the first pick that's
Watson their second pick that belongs to
Cleveland that's Tyrann Mathieu they
picked up another ten million in cap
space to get rid of Osweiler
and you could say they use seven of that
pin to bring in Tyrann Mathieu and if
they were having a party they could
bring both those guys out as their first
two takes
and nobody's complaining and ultimately
they swap number ones last year gave up
a 1 this year I think they were given up
three number ones if they knew what
Watson was capable of doing as a rookie
when he averaged
34 points a game 39 in his last five he
was on a pace for 43 touchdowns people
here wait to get him back on the field
how's he looking that's you know
everything he's done in offseason
program Bill O'Brien has told us several
times he's ahead of schedule until they
actually start getting serious during
OTAs in the minicamp he won't be doing
any 11 on leavens but he'll be doing
everything else and then they expect him
to be a hundred percent for training
camp house JJ Watt it could he possibly
be ending his career everybody wonders
that rich you know he doesn't know he
told us last week he said I can sit up
here and tell you how great I feel now
fired up I ain't but till I get on the
field you know who's going to believe me
he doesn't know O'Brien said one thing
I've learned with lot never bet against
him he turned 29 he's very motivated but
being motivated physically and
emotionally is not the same as being
able to go out there and do it but rich
and he could play every game and say get
seven or eight sacks and play the run
well with cloudy and merciless they
would be more than happy with that would
you say John McLean fair to say despite
the fact obviously that Watson could be
the difference maker that the jaguars
have passed the Texans in the AFC South
well last year they did they were the
only team that had their quarterback
healthy all season and they other now in
Robinson I don't think that a major
injury texans at 20 on our 13 starters
and of course with Watson played he
showed he's capable of beating anybody
anywhere he put 57 on Tennessee and then
the Titans ended up in the second round
of the playoffs so it's going to
probably come down again if luck plays
and Watson's healthy which quarterback
stays healthy the entire season but
Jacksonville has to be considered the
favorite because they want it last year
John McClain here on the Rich Eisen show
I'd be remiss if I didn't do a little
bit of a Houston round up since you know
obviously Philadelphia calls itself the
city of Champions but Houston could
absolutely stake a little bit of claim
to that and they would absolutely be
able to claim it should the Houston
Rockets win at all they'd have the
reigning champs in bass
all as well as as baseball in that
regard how nervous was the town halftime
of Game four in Minnesota and relieved
after the third quarter of Game four in
Minnesota they won't admit to being
nervous but the fact is until a third
quarter of that game the Rockets had not
played anywhere near as good as they did
in regular season when they blew out the
Timberwolves and three games in lost and
won the other one by nine so people were
worried and all of a sudden they score
50 led by harden now their figure
they're going to blow out the
Timberwolves tonight wrap this series up
but rich because of the regular season
when they had the best record by far
people are going to be really
disappointed if they don't win a
championship well I guess it all comes
to look I mean it looks like they're
gonna get Donovan Mitchell and hew in
Utah which obviously they should
dispatch a team being led by a rookie
despite how remarkably well he's played
in his first four playoff games and then
there's either Golden State or the
red-hot pelicans how how do you see this
playing out over the next couple of
weeks
I've watched almost every game they
played this year and this is the deepest
team they've ever had this is also the
most talented team top to bottom they've
got hard and they don't have a large one
Chris Paul getting him turned out to be
such a shrewd move by Daryl Morey Jim
Paul helps harden a lot takes up the
slack when harden slumps which isn't
very often they dominated the pelicans
and in Mitchell's tremendous but the
Rockets are loaded with weapons and
they're fun to watch because they're
their high-scoring and the difference
this year rich is their defense has been
really good harden is played by far the
best defense we're talking about Mike
D'Antoni's team ranking in the top six I
believe in defense and that's amazing
and ultimately if they're going to win a
title that'll have a lot to do with it
and as much to do about last night's
real sports where Bryant Gumbel had an
interesting exchange with Derek Jeter
and in the conversation of the Marlins
everybody's pointing to the Astros
see what the Astros did they essentially
tanked they got all of these young
prospects and now look at him I mean 16
and 9 and I know they got another great
start from Gerrit Cole and knocked
around Otani with nothing to show for it
over the last two days against the
Angels but it's clear that the Astros
are are a class in the in the American
League and at the end of the day when it
all comes down to it a tough place to
and it'll be a very tough out in October
certainly in that building is it fair to
equate what the Marlins are doing now
with what the Astros did to build first
of all every time Jeter had an answer I
saw his nose grow a little more each
time he spoke and of course that's what
he's doing it looks like there's some
other team's doing it so many of them
already out of the race and season has
barely started now the key is you can do
it you can high have high draft choices
you can trade veterans for young guys
you can you can claim them on waivers
you can do a lot of things but you got a
hit you're not going to hit all of them
I look around their infield Yuri you'll
agree l first base came from Cuba Altuve
was already here drafted Korea number
one overall Berkman I mean brakeman
second overall in the same draft they
got called tucker they drafted Lance
McCullers they signed traded for Charlie
Morton trade for Justin Verlander and
then traded for Gerrit Cole who's been
fabulous and in Kaikohe started slowly
'he's pitched well the last two games
they're they're five dinkus starters and
I've never seen an astro pitching staff
this deep Martin had his worst game last
night Joe Smith stunk it up out in I was
there three rows behind home plate
watching Showtime and it was a sight to
behold rich on if you haven't been out
there to see him check him out because
it's weird to see and God not in uniform
run out to the mound when they want to
talk to him if his interpreter of course
and we're saying the interpreter needs a
uniform I mean I know you you went to
see him Brockman in in in Anaheim I did
see him in October he lasted only two
innings but he's definitely a sensation
and I know the Yankees are up next and I
know I've got a promoter
read on the NFL Network Fox coverage for
the Angels and Yankees coming up this
weekend they're gonna put him front and
center for that last one for you John I
would be remiss if I did not ask you
just to go back in your draft memory
your favorite draft story from either a
draft room or a player who got drafted
any I guess safe for work story that's
come across your your brain or you've
covered yourself from back in the day as
we're here for the first ever draft in
the state of Texas in the state of Texas
when bum Phillips traded tight end Jimmy
Giles and a number one pick to Tampa in
1978 and drafted Earl Campbell which
started to love you blue era and Earl
still is the greatest player in this
city's history and still is a beloved
figure and I anytime you ask anybody
about it draft here and great trap moves
through the decades like deshaun Watson
people first and foremost will always be
roe Campbell unless deshaun Watson leads
them to a Super Bowl victory yeah and
again that's the whole point it does not
matter what you give up as long as you
get the right guy
it just doesn't that's the way it's been
obviously forevermore always love
chatting with you John we'll see you
soon hopefully great it's my pleasure
have a great draft you got it John
McLean the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience